yeah I've been trying to think of
something to say related to the burning
boat no I got nothing
[Music]
broadchurch episode 4 continuing down
this particular journey so this episode
opened with the burning boat which we
still don't really have the full details
on on what's going on with that the
investigation deepens we find out some
unpleasant things about another member
of the town which I feel he's gonna be
the mo of the show as a whole and we're
also getting pointed towards a few other
people who if not are directly involved
obviously have stuff that they want to
hide and that's overall that seems to be
becoming the motif of the show which is
not just the death of Danny and the
investigation into that and what
happened to him but also all the things
that people don't want to be uncovered
that will be over the course of an
investigation as thorough as the death
of a child so the sort of things that
under normal circumstances and very
clearly from how from how Ellie Miller
acts in regards to the townspeople it's
very obvious that the relationship
between the police and the town up to
this point has been oh well that we
don't have to worry about that if it
wasn't directly related to whatever they
were dealing with well now everything
matters there isn't an obvious answer so
they have to dig into everything and
everybody seems really nervous and
that's where we get to Jack played by
David Bradley spoilers should know that
who was the the newsagent and so we find
out that he they painted in very vague
terms they say he he had an encounter
with an underage you know sex with an
underage individual we don't know if it
was a boy or a girl we don't know how
young they were we don't know you know
if he got it on with a 16 year old or or
an 11 year old and I have two one
if how they they're keeping it I figure
it's got to do with one of two things
either it's because that level of detail
the show just didn't want to get into
because it's kind of icky or if it's
because they're trying to keep it
intentionally vague just to muddy the
waters all the more and obviously having
a very long time ago because it predates
the sex offender registry which puts it
in the neighborhood I mean I don't know
when the sex offender registries went up
in in the UK but if it's parallel to the
u.s. at all that that puts it you know
30 years plus so but he's the latest
sort of favored suspect but again we're
four episodes into an 8 episode series
so I'm thinking is probably not him
although we're far enough in that I
wouldn't be surprised if he somehow
factors into it like where my head went
is if if not his uh the victim he was
actually caught with if somebody that he
messed around with and messed up as a
result of that is somehow a player in
this if the damage that he did to
someone when they were younger affected
them in a way that has led to this other
thing I wouldn't be shocked by that I'm
not
now how much way to point out because
there was a lot of emphasis on this
happened before he came to this town and
given the impression that were given
that most people in this town were born
in this town and didn't and don't leave
this town maybe not but that's sort of
where my head went as I mean I say
obvious in the way my mind works the
obvious direction to go in terms of how
that ties in to everything else and kind
of like I said we're kind of just
finding a town of not good people which
you know is probably most towns on the
planet if you dig deep enough so you
know mark I
yeah I'm still annoyed with him with
with this and I still feel like they
have they have failed to just
fight him not cooperating with the
police over something as basic as an
affair I'm still annoyed with that
especially because he didn't even seem
excessively shaken up when when his wife
would Jodie Whittaker said to him you
know I know about it you know she said
at that point where he was gonna just
sit in front of a camera anyway and I'm
sure that was done on purpose it
wouldn't make a huge scene but even you
know that moment before when I Cameron
had to keep it together just looking I'm
going you look upset frustrated you
don't look devastated by this so again
whether that's a fall to the writing or
a fall to the acting or is gonna get
covered and I'll feel better about it by
the time the show ends no we'll see I
feel like there's a number of things
that were hinted at as things that
matter that have yet to show up again so
I'm keeping an eye out for them mainly
having to do with Danny's friend and
there was mention of the computers how
good they were on computers so that's
gonna that's gonna come back up I'm sure
the the other thing I think the thing I
found most interesting about this was
something that actually as it was
happening I loved and then the show
itself pointed it out and I resented the
show for that because I was like yeah I
saw that on my own
don't patronize me so I was really
enjoying watching Miller shift in her
dynamics with the people in the town
just the way she was talking them the
way she was questioning them I forgot I
forget right now who what she was
talking to but they were talking to
somebody and she was just starting to do
the rapid-fire questions thing that
David Tennant's character does and I
remember thinking she's she's seeing
them alessa's her neighbors and more as
people of interest as witnesses as
potential suspects and this is this is
the start of things changing for her and
then it actually gets point out she says
I hate how I'm becoming more like you
she says to town I'm like ah yeah I know
show I saw that on my own don't oh like
that that's a
that's a moment that annoys me because
it shows a lack of faith in the audience
for them to get it based off a really
good interaction that you had prior to
that so that irritated me that's it it's
a character development I really like
it's just that you know sign posting it
on principle annoys me we're learning a
little bit more about tenants character
that he's divorced that he has a kid
he's obviously got some serious damage
like initially I thought it was just
gonna be shaking you know shaking up if
he has like PTSD or something but it
really does look like he might have a
serious physical health issue which I
hadn't counted on I didn't see that
coming not entirely sure how that will
play out again I'm it's still balancing
pretty well the the character drama and
the the elements of the mystery coming
forward oh I hate this reporter I hate
that she talked this family into giving
an interview and becoming front-page
news oh I hate her
I think this reporter so much and the
psychic keeps coming back and uh I'm
leaning towards he thinks it's real I
mean up did those those are the options
you know II either he is uh he is a
complete scam artist in which case he
seems overly dedicated to this and he
seemed overly shaken up when he got
turned away or he is unbalanced and
genuinely believes what he's saying even
though to back it up he resorts to crap
like cold reading which I mentioned last
time so yeah that's where I'm leading
leaning and I'm wondering how that's
going to that's gonna factor and I
wouldn't be shocked if he ends up being
the killer honestly because if it is a
mental unbalancing but of course we've
got all these other people that there's
obviously weird stuff going on there's
the other plumber there's the the house
cleaners so that there's obviously a
whole lot of other crap that's going to
be uncovered in the next four episodes
or so and I'll be curious to see I just
I I don't want the
uncovering of individual people's BS to
overtake the mystery because I'm still
intrigued by the mystery but again so
far it's still balanced pretty well I'm
just I'm just nervous that the the carts
kind of tip one way or the other pretty
soon and the the the priest is gonna
have damage he there's gotta be
something messed up about him I don't
know what I did it'll be something I'm
calling that right now because that he's
like one of the only lead characters we
keep coming back to where it doesn't
seem like he has an issue and I'm like
nope not in this show not in this town
so we'll see what happens so broadchurch
episode four those are my thoughts have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do so just
support me on patreon like subscribe
follow me on Twitter
I got podcasts maybe I might be on
hiatus I'm recording this well in
advance
I got t-shirts I know I got those links
for all that stuff and more is down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]